We've talked a lot about marketing
goals throughout the course.
Now these goals are really important,
but
they're not worth anything if all
you do is mention them in a slide.
You need a way to follow them and
to ensure you're on track
with meatier goals.
>> You have to be honest and
find the most accurate metrics
to measure these goals.
>> You're looking for
something that is clear and that will
help you to evaluate your progress.
Think about your car dashboard.
The fuel gauge indicator turns on
the light to transfer the message.
No more gas, soon enough,
you won't be able to keep driving.
You need metrics that are so
clear and relevant to your goal,
that every event tells you something
about the health of your business.
>> Your metrics must
be measured correctly.
You don't want inaccurate or
incomplete data.
This could lead you down the wrong path.
It has to be simple, if it's too
complex to explain how to relate it
to your business and marketing,
then there's something wrong.
Let's look at our goals for
aBARKment that we created in lesson.two.